Ron DeSantis is the governor of Florida
and 2024 presidential candidate so a lot
to go at you want to talk Prime Time
great advice for Republicans or you want
to talk about how the New York city
mayor just said Joe Biden is destroying
this town
well Jesse I think you're right with a
lot of Republicans and being scared we
have not though in Florida we've done
what we needed to do when I first became
Governor we banned Sanctuary cities you
know what a lot of these weak need
Republicans said they said that Latino
voters were going to rebel against us
because we did that guess what in any
poll that was ever done Hispanics in
Florida supported us Banning Sanctuary
cities more than any other demographic
when we've sent troops to the border to
help Texas we've had strong support
across the state especially with our
Hispanic community and when we
transported the illegal aliens to
beautiful Martha's Vineyard the
Venezuelans down in Florida were very
supportive of that so people want the
rule of law and I would say particularly
Hispanic Americans want the rule of law
all those liberal politicians that you
just showed they're articulating why you
can't have open borders they're doing in
a way that may be a little bit more
politically correct than they should be
but they are articulating open borders
as a a disaster you're seeing what's
happening in New York City just think of
what's happening at these border towns
think of all the fentanyl that's pouring
in think of the sex trafficking and the
human trafficking we have a president
that ceded control of our Southern
border to the Mexican drug cartels it's
humiliating as a country to see this
happening and it is wrong and we've got
to be strong to say we will reverse all
of these policies yeah they have to be
reversed day one I want to hit you with
something else coveted I know you listen
to Howard every day on Sirius Howard
Stern and it could be a little sticky
he's preparing for lockdowns listen
I'm going crazy with this my wife yelled
at me last night we got into a fight you
know how paranoid I am about getting
covered I haven't gotten it and been
pretty safe and I really don't want to
get it then all of a sudden they
announced there's a new strain of covid
and it's on the rise and you know people
are being hospitalized it's time to go
back down into lockdown and I'm like you
mean I'm just emerging and now I'm going
back into lockdown it makes me nervous
I'm neurotic but it's not just Howard
Whoopi is quarantining alone with a mask
watch
and just have Colvin I'm still testing
positive apparently I have to have a
clear chest before I can come back so it
might be a couple of days I can't wait
to get back and hang out but in until
then it's me and my mask and I'm sort of
confined to my room well we hope Wolfie
recovers but Biden declared victory over
the virus last summer and now these big
celebrities on these platforms are
panicking and Biden can't control that
phenomenon I mean he has to be
sustaining major damage has the
president lost total control of this
well yeah you see you have school
districts in Maryland now imposing
kn-95 mask mandates on school children
are you kidding me we know that doesn't
work we know that's harmful I can tell
you in the State of Florida we obviously
fought back against all that when it was
happening but we've enacted permanent
protections you have a civil right as a
Floridian to breathe clean air without
someone telling you to put on a mask
whether it's your business you go into
whether it's a government agency nothing
no Mass mandates no mandates on school
children no covid vax mandates and we've
even banned gain of function research I
think part of the problem with this
Jesse is a lot of these leftists they
think that these lockdown policies
worked they did not work and nobody's
been held accountable from fauci on down
I've promised to bring a reckoning to
CDC NIH FDA all these agencies that lied
to the American people repeatedly
because if we don't have a reckoning and
we don't have accountability they are
going to try to do it again and that's
exactly what you see in some of these
jurisdictions around the country we all
have to rise up as Americans and just
say no what would a DeSantis Reckoning
look like
well first of all you take something
like an FDA they're basically of
subsidiary of big Pharma we're not going
to allow people in the FDA to leave the
FDA and cash out in Pharma it's like a
revolving door that's why you have them
approving an mRNA vacs for six-month-old
babies for covid there was no evidence
to support that they're doing it because
of that relationship we're going to
clean house at places like the CDC they
didn't follow the science during covid
they followed the narrative during covet
and that was very very destructive so we
will clean house with Personnel you're
going to have people in with me like my
Surgeon General in Florida Dr Joseph
latipo you have people like Jay
bhattacharya from Stanford these are
people that were right about covid from
day one they were pilloried by a very
politicized scientific establishment but
they stood their ground and they've been
proving right those are the people that
need to be in positions not the
political actors that we've seen over
the last four or five years you see
getting pumped up for the big Fox
Business debate in a couple weeks
governor
yeah no it should be fun and I you know
I'm assuming because it's Fox Business
we'll talk a little bit more about the
economy than we did in the first debate
because I can tell you under Biden uh
people are hurting and his policies are
driving uh your grocery bills to be more
expensive your gas is going up and he
just took a lot of oil out of
circulation in Alaska uh his vision is
five six seven dollars a gallon gas my
vision is open up energy let's be energy
dominant and let's get back to two
dollars a gallon gas that's what the
American people need all right well Dana
Perino my co-host on the five shall be
moderating and she's got some tough ones
for you so you better be well prepared
she's tough
all right I'm sure you'll be ready
thanks so much Governor hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else